علمتني دبابه تي 72 هذه يستعد الطاقم
الاوكرانى لشنه هجوم مضاد بهدف استعاده
السيطره على الضفه اليمنى من نهر دنيرو
يستعجلها هؤلاء الجنود شن العمليه
العسكريه خشيه سوء الاحوال الجويه التي
تحول الارض الى وحل تصعب معه حركه
الدبابات والمشاد رغم فعاليتها في الرمي
وفي المناوره كما يستعجلون ايضا نهايه
الحرب
يريد ان تنضم اوكرانيا الى اوروبا
للذهاب الى مكان اخر للحصول على المال
العمليات العسكريه المستمره اغرقت جزءا
واسعا من اوكرانيا في ظلام دامس كما هو
الحال مع العاصمه كاف الرئيس الاوكراني
اعترف بصعوبه الظروف
الكهربائي عن كيف وعن سته مناطق اخرى اكثر
من اربعه ملايين و500,000 مستهلك هم الان
دون كهرباء واغلبهم في كيف وفي المناطق
المحيطه بها ان الامر صعب جدا
المنيع في مواجهه القوات الاوكرانيه التي
تقترب منها منذ اسابيع وسقوطها سيكون ضربه
معنويه كبرى للجيش الروسي